The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Welcome to 6.890,
Algorithmic Lower Bounds,
Fun with Hardness Proofs.
I am your host, Erik Demaine.
We have on my left Jayson Lynch
and Sarah Eisenstat, your TAs.
First question is what
is this class about?
The tag line is
hardness made easy.
In general, we're interested
in proving problems hard.
Proving that there's no fast
algorithms to solve problems
under certain assumptions.
And the goal is to give
you a practical guide
and give you lots of experience
in how to prove problems hard,
to make that an easy process.
There's a lot of
technique involved,
and the more experience
you get improving hardness,
it becomes relatively
straightforward to take
whatever problem you're
interested in and prove it hard
So the three of us
are pretty good at it,
and our goal is to share
with you that expertise so
that everyone's good at it.
This is not a complexity class.
Because there are lots of
computational complexity
classes at MIT.
So we're not going
to talk about lots
of beautiful deep
mathematics about relations
between complexity classes.
We're just going to use
a lot of those results
wholesale without proving them.
And you can take one of the
many computational complexity
classes to get that background.
I will tell you everything you
need to know about complexity.
So if you've taken
a complexity class,
there will be a small
amount of repetition.
Most of it will be contained
in today's lecture.
But very little repetition, but
also no background required.
I do expect you to have a
background in algorithms,
because we take a kind of
algorithmic perspective.
I call it an anti-algorithmic
perspective, if you like.
And so, yeah.
So that's what this class is.
Why would you want
to take this class?
Why prove hardness?
Well, the main reason
is to show that you
can't design algorithms
in whatever model
you're interested in.
That encourages you either
to change the problem, like
to look for
approximation algorithms,
or fixed parameter algorithms.
That's, of course, the
topics of algorithms class.
Our goal is to prove
when these things are not
possible in this class.
We're going to master
a lot of techniques.
You'll see a lot of key problems
to reduce from to your problem.
Get a lot of proof
styles that are
quite common in the
literature, but unless you've
done them and
experienced them, it's
hard to know what to look for.
And one of the big ideas
in this class is gadgets.
And you may have
seen gadgets before,
but we're going to explore
gadgets to their fullest.
The idea of taking lots
of small components
and combining them together.
Even if you don't
care about hardness,
I think this class is a
lot of fun for two reasons.
Maybe three.
One is that you see
lots of cool connections
between different problems
that you might not think
are related at first glance.
Most of the problems
in this class
are equivalent to each other.
And it's all about proving that.
That's the goal.
We'll also study
lots of fun problems,
like Super Mario Brothers.
We'll NP-complete today.
Tetris, we'll do in
a lecture or two.
There are also serious problems,
so if you don't like fun,
don't worry.
And in general,
proving problems hard
is really like solving a puzzle.
And it's a lot of fun.
And this is one
of the rare areas
where you can basically
play with puzzles all day,
and in the end have
publishable papers.
So we're going to do
that in particular
through an open problem
session, which is optional.
If you want to
solve open problems
that no one knows
the answer to, we
will try to do it once a week.
We'll be sending email
with a call for times when
that's ideal for everybody.
We talked about background
and requirements.
So first requirement
of the class
is to fill out the survey, which
is circulating Does anyone not
have a survey?
Good.
Everyone has one.
So fill that out, so
we know who you are.
You should also join
the mailing list.
By filling out that
survey, you should auto
join the mailing list.
But just in case, if you
haven't, the mailing list
is on the course website.
Yeah.
Good.
Another requirement
is to attend lectures.
You're doing good
on that so far.
And you'll have scribe--
I would guess at
this scale, you'll
scribe once, probably in a team.
But we will figure that
out as time goes on.
Again, they'll be email about
signing up for scribing.
Scribing is taking
notes in the lecture
so we have another
form of notes.
There will be
something like five P
sets every two to three weeks.
The first one will go
out Tuesday is the plan.
And then the big
part of the class
is the project and presentation,
so the final project,
you could do it on
almost anything related
to the content of the class.
Typical projects are do
something new theoretically,
prove a problem hard, find
some nice open problems, survey
existing material, something
that's not covered in class.
You can code something.
I think in this context,
the most natural thing
to do is to visualize
cool proofs that we
cover in class in a new way.
You could contribute
to Wikipedia,
or you could make
some art piece,
like a sculpture,
or a performance,
or whatever you want
related to hardness proofs.
That's your project
possibilities.
So what is in this class?
I will look at what
specific topics are covered.
This is on the website.
So a lot of the class will
be about NP-completeness,
which I will define in a bit.
But we'll also look
at even harder--
these are all notions of no
polynomial time algorithm.
We'll do even harder notions
then NP, like PSPACE and X
time, and so on.
In particular, we'll be studying
those in the context of games
and puzzles, and there's a whole
theory called games, puzzles,
and computation, the
topic of this book,
which we will talk
about at length.
Then, we will go to
inapproximability.
This is not necessarily in
order, so I should say then.
But we'll talk about when you
cannot find good approximation
algorithms, and what good means
depends on what sort of problem
you're looking at, and when
you cannot find fixed parameter
algorithms, which are fast
algorithms when the optimal
solutions happens to be small.
So that's all about
not polynomial.
Then, there's a
small amount of work
on understanding the polynomial
aspect for small polynomials,
distinguishing almost
linear time from n
squared time or n cubed time.
That sort of thing.
Then there are other
sorts of problems.
We can think about less
common types of problems,
like where you want to count
the number of solutions
instead of just
find one, or tell
whether the solution is unique.
There's some economic
game theory stuff.
This existential
theory, the reals,
comes up in some
geometric settings.
And if there's time,
we'll talk a little bit
about undecidability,
although that's
a pretty different world.
That's where there's
no algorithm given
any finite time bound.
So that's in a nutshell
what's the entire class is.
Today, we're going to do
a sort of crash course
on computational complexity.
Most of what you should need
for the entire course, I think,
will fit in about 40 minutes.
Maybe 50 minutes.
Something.
And that will serve
as a guideline.
If anything's not clear, if I
go too fast, feel free to stop,
ask questions during
class or after class.
And let's see.
So we have some--
there's no real
textbook for the class,
but there are two
recommended reading books.
They are Garey and Johnson.
Computers and
Intractability is the title.
Most people call it
Garey and Johnson.
This is an old book
from pretty much
early on in the world
of NP completeness,
but it's still a
really good book.
So that's good to check out.
And then there's my
book with Bob Hearn.
This is Bob Hearn's PhD
thesis at MIT, Games, Puzzles,
and Computation.
This is available
electronically for free online
to all MIT people.
So if you look it
up in MIT libraries,
it's actually linked right here.
So you're seeing that base.
You can get an electronic copy.
If you want to buy one,
talk to me or order it.
There's a couple other
links on the website.
There was some followup
to the Garey and Johnson
book by Johnson and some
other cool websites.
All right.
So I think that is the
administrative part.
Now we can start the
fun part of the class.
So let's do our crash
course on complexity.
So if you've seen complexity
before, some of this
will be review.
We start with our favorite
class of problems that can
be solved in polynomial time.
Say on a RAM, I should
specify model of computation
and exactly what a
problem is, but I'll
be a little bit informal here.
Polynomial time means
n to some constant,
where n is the size of
the problem instance.
And we will talk
a little bit more
about subtleties in defining n.
But usually, polynomial
time is pretty clear.
This is what we consider
good algorithms.
An example of something
we consider bad
is exponential time.
So x is going to be all
the problems that can
be solved in exponential time.
And exponential's a little
less a uniquely defined,
but I'll define it this way.
I think this is the
usual definition for x. .
So 2 to a polynomial.
Of course, it could
be 3 if you prefer.
Any constant will
be the same here.
This constant dwarfs
any constant there.
So that is-- this is a
huge class, any problem you
can in exponential time.
Most problems can be
solved exponential time,
though not all.
Most problems we
encounter, I should say.
And then I'll define
one more just for kicks.
R is a recursively
enumerable problems,
or recursive problems.
These are all the problems that
can be solved in finite time.
Always.
And these are all
worst case bounds.
So I'm going to have
a running picture.
This is my favorite
picture to draw.
We have on the x-axis
a somewhat vague notion
of computational difficulty.
What you might call
hardness colloquially.
This is a bit informal,
but it's still a useful way
to think about things.
So this initial
chunk here is going
to be P. I'm going to
leave in some space
to fill in some other things.
And probably go to here.
And this part is
going to be EXP,
and then everything to
the left of this line
are the problems that are
solvable in finite time.
Everything to the
right of that line
is not solvable by algorithms.
That would be undecidable.
OK.
So obviously, anything
we saw in polynomial time
can also be solved
in exponential time.
That's all that this is saying.
Cool.
So I have examples.
I'll give you some
examples to think about.
For example, n by n Chess.
So this is, I give you a Chess
configuration on an n by n,
and I want to know,
let's say, white to move.
Can white force a win?
This turns out to be
solvable in exponential time,
and is not solvable
in polynomial time.
So that's a nice result.
Something we will get to.
Another example is Tetris,
suitably generalized.
So we're thinking
about problems where
you have all the information.
Usually in Tetris, you
don't know all the pieces
that are going to come.
But supposing you knew
the future, I give you
the entire sequence of pieces
that are going to come,
sort of a Tetris puzzle.
They used to publish these
in Nintendo Power Magazine.
And you want to
know, can I survive
from this board position?
Can I survive this
sequence of pieces
This is also in EXP.
You can solve this
in exponential time.
That's a little more obvious.
But we don't know whether
it's in P. Probably it's not,
and we'll see why in a moment.
If you've taken an
algorithms class,
you know tons of
examples of problems
that are in P, like shortest
paths or lots of good things.
Halting problem, you've
probably heard of.
Kind of a classic.
Halting problem is, given an
algorithm, does it terminate,
or given some computer
code, does it terminate?
This is not recursive,
meaning there's
no algorithm to solve it in
finite time in the worst case.
There's a more
depressing result,
which is that in
fact, most problems--
let's say most decision
problems are not in R.
Most problems cannot be
solved by an algorithm.
If you haven't seen that,
it's cool result. Basically,
the proof is that the number
of problems in the universe
is about 2 to the N. And
the number of algorithms
is only about N. So if you
know set theory, great.
Otherwise, ignore this sentence.
So you could think of an
algorithm as a number.
It's like, you take this
string and convert it
to a giant number.
So that's integers over here.
You can think of
problems as a mapping
from inputs to Yes or No.
Yes or No is the 2.
Inputs is the N. This is
the same as real numbers.
This is the integers, and there
are a lot more real numbers
than integers.
You probably heard of that.
So this means most problems have
no algorithm if an algorithm
can only solve one problem.
That's the sad news of life.
Luckily, most of the
problems we tend to pose
do have an algorithm, and
it's more about P versus EXP
that this class is about.
So let's go to more
interesting things.
I'm going to define a class
NP, which is in between here.
In between P and EXP.
So as I said, decision
problems are problems
where the answer is Yes or No.
There are lots of possible
definitions of NP.
I will cover two.
I would like there
to be an algorithm
to solve the problem
in polynomial time,
but not in a regular
model of computation,
But with something I
call a lucky algorithm.
Lucky algorithm
comes to a decision,
and it always makes
the right one.
It's just lucky.
It doesn't have any reason to
believe that's the right one.
It just always makes the
right choice given the choice
between two options, let's say.
So this is, you
make lucky guesses.
You always guess the right one.
It's a little bit biased
in a way that I should say.
So let me be a
little more precise.
This is called a
non-deterministic model.
And the N in NP is
non-deterministic.
So the idea is
that the algorithm
makes a series of guesses.
It could do it at the
beginning, or could do it
in the middle of
the computation.
And eventually, it
outputs an answer.
So it's going to say
either Yes or No.
And what we guarantee in this
weird non-deterministic lucky
model of computation is that
you will be led to a Yes answer
if it's possible.
So it guesses--
this is asymmetric.
So what this means is say
you run your magical lucky
algorithm, and it outputs No.
That means no matter
what set of choices
you made for each guess, you
would always get to a No.
If you get a Yes
answer, you just
know there's some set of guesses
that lead to a Yes answer.
So one is an existential
quantifier, one's universal.
So this is asymmetric.
There is a notion of CoNP,
which is exactly the reverse.
CoNP, you let's say
flip Yes with No.
So CoNP, you prefer no
answers if you can get them.
All right.
So let me give another
definition of NP.
Another way to think of the
same definition, really.
So you can also
think of NP problems
as problems that have solutions
that are relatively succinct
and can be checked
in polynomial time.
I guess really they need to
be checkable efficiently.
So what you can think
of this as saying is,
well, every time I
make a guess, I'll
write down whether I went
left or went right in my maze,
I guess.
And so that you could
think of as a certificate.
If you know what the right
sequence of guesses are,
of course, you can
run the algorithm,
because it's a polynomial
time algorithm.
Conversely, if I don't have
the solution to the problem,
yet I'm told that it exists,
at the top of my algorithm,
I could just guess what that
solution is, and then check it.
So if I'm given
such an algorithm,
I can convert it into
a lucky algorithm.
If I'm given a
lucky algorithm, I
can convert it into one of
these checking algorithms.
OK.
So let's do an example.
Let's say Tetris is in NP.
So if I give you a board, and
I give you a sequence of pieces
that are going to come.
How would I prove to
you that I can survive
those sequence of pieces?
AUDIENCE: Say where they go?
PROFESSOR: Just
say where they go.
Say what sequence or moves I
press, and at what times say.
Just where should
I drop each piece?
So then all you need to do
for this definition is check
that that's about
solution that you never
have to push a piece
up, for example,
to get it into the
right position.
Or you can think
of the same thing
as an algorithm
that says, oh, OK.
Every time I have to press left,
or right, or wait a second,
or push down, I'll
just guess which
one to do, and then do that.
So these are the same
algorithm, essentially.
And that's why Tetris is in NP.
In general, let's see.
Every problem that I can
solve in polynomial time,
of course, I can solve in
non-deterministic polynomial
time, so that's
that containment.
If I have an NP
problem and I want
to solve it in
exponential time, well, I
could just simulate all the
possible guessing paths,
because I run for
only polynomial time.
And so for each one,
maybe I have two choices.
I'll just try both.
I'll do this sort
of depth research.
And yeah.
I have exponential is
exactly 2 to that polynomial,
so I can afford to branch
in both directions.
So I guess my guesses
here are just binary.
I could afford to branch
in both directions,
and eventually see whether
any of them leads to a Yes.
I could also figure out whether
any of them leads to a No.
But in general, NP
is contained in EXP.
Cool.
Still not too interesting.
Where it gets
interesting is when
we start talking about
hardness, which is next.
I should mention big open
question is whether there's
any problem in
here in NP minus P.
This is the same as P
equals NP open problem.
Most sane people in the universe
believe P does not equal NP.
What this means intuitively is
that you can't engineer luck.
Luck shouldn't exist
in the real world.
You can't just like,
go one way or the other
and always make
the right choice.
You could make a random choice.
You could try both choices.
But you shouldn't be able to
always make the right choice
for all problems.
That seems insane.
So if you believe that, you
believe P does not equal NP
and you believe there's some
things in between those two
lines.
But we don't know,
unfortunately.
So let me talk about hardness.
So if I have some
complexity class X,
X could be NP, or
EXP at this point.
P we won't talk about.
P hardness is a little weird.
I'm not going to define this
formally until a little bit
later in today's class.
So problem is X-hard if
it's sort of the hardest
problem in the class X, if it's
as hard as every other problem
in X. Actually, this
problem may not be in X,
so I should say it's hard
as every problem in X.
So what that means in this
picture is the following.
So every problem from
here onward is EXP-hard.
And every problem from
here onward is NP-hard.
Whoops.
Here.
We won't talk about P hardness.
That's a notion in
parallel computing.
I mean, maybe we'll have
time to talk about it,
but it's not
currently on the plan.
So this is the lower
bound side, right?
You're proving that
you're at least as
hard as the very
hardest problem in NP,
or you're at least as hard
as the problem in EXP.
The reason, the only reason,
I know that Chess is not NP
is because I know that
Chess is actually X-hard.
I know it's at least as hard
as all problems solvable
an exponential time.
And there's a great theorem
called time hierarchy theorem
that tells you that P does
not equal EXP in particular.
So we know there are
some problems in EXP that
are not in P. Some problems that
require exponential time can't
be done in polynomial time.
And we know that Chess is
as hard as all of them,
so in particular, it also can't
be solved in polynomial time.
Mind you, though, I haven't
defined what as hard as a means
yet, but I will get there.
Another good term to
know is X-completeness.
This is just the and of two
things, being X-hard and being
in X. So in my picture, this
dot right here is NP-complete.
And this dot right here is--
got to write it this way--
is X-complete.
OK.
I already mentioned
that Chess is in EXP.
So in fact, Chess is X-complete.
It means there's an upper bound
saying that you can solve it
in exponential time.
There's a lower bound
saying that it's at least as
hard as everything in EXP.
And both are true, so you would
know you're kind of right here.
From the resolution
of this picture,
that's all you could
hope to know about Chess.
So, good.
One more class of problems
good to know about,
and it will come up a lot in
games, is the notion of PSPACE.
So so far, we've only
thought about time.
But usually, we
measure algorithms
in terms of time and space.
How much memory does
your algorithm use?
And so PSPACE is going to be, I
guess, say let's say problems.
As you might guess, this
is problems solvable
in polynomial space.
In general, if you can solve
a problem in polynomial space,
you can solve it in
exponential time,
because there are only
exponentially many states
of your machine if you
only have polynomial space.
So PSPACE fits here
in between NP and EXP.
And of course, there's
PSPACE-hard and
PSPACE-complete.
If you don't remember
anything from today
except one blackboard,
remember this blackboard.
It's like the cheat sheet
to everything we've defined.
You just have to remember
what all the letters mean.
But not too hard.
So that's pretty much all
the classes we'll be using.
There are a few others.
I'm sorry.
I'll give you one example to
go with our other examples.
The problem we'll look
at today is Rush Hour.
This is a one
player puzzle, where
you're trying to move the
cars, and they could only
go vertically or horizontally.
This is in PSPACE, which
is maybe not so obvious.
And actually, it's
PSPACE-complete.
So this is from the
diagram, PSPACE-complete
is harder than NP-complete.
Now of course, we don't actually
know whether these two points
are the same.
It's kind of annoying.
We don't know whether these
two points are the same.
This whole thing could collapse.
We do know these two
points are different.
So somewhere here, or here, or
here, we have a positive range.
Most people believe all of
these have problems in them,
so none of these
things are the same.
It could be NP-complete is
the same as PSPACE-complete.
But again, most people
believe these are different.
So in some sense, Rush
Hour, which is here,
is harder than
Tetris, which is here.
Cool.
And if you believe that either
one of these is non-empty,
then we know that Rush Hour
does not have a polynomial time
algorithm.
So to show that Rush Hour is
not in P, you have a choice.
You could prove either
one of these as non-empty.
For Tetris, you have
to prove this one.
So you'd be less famous
if you prove this one.
Still pretty famous, but you
wouldn't win the million dollar
bounty that's on P versus NP.
All right.
There are bigger classes.
We talked about
exponential time.
You can, of course, talk
about exponential space.
In general, these interleave.
You go polynomial
time, polynomial space,
exponential time, exponential
space, doubly exponential time,
doubly exponential
space, and so on.
That's the order in
which they occur.
The only things we know
is that polynomial time is
different from
exponential time is
different from doubly
exponential time,
or any function of time, really.
And we know that
polynomial space
is different from exponential
space is different from doubly
exponential space.
But we don't know
about the interrelation
between time and space.
That's one of the big questions.
The other big question
is non-determinism.
One fun fact you should know
is that PSPACE equals NPSPACE.
This is a useful fact.
NPSPACE is non-deterministic
polynomial space.
So you take a lucky
algorithm, and you
don't guarantee how
much time it takes,
it will be a most
exponential time.
You only guarantee the
amount of space it uses
is, at most, polynomial.
This is a theorem
called Savages Theorem,
and it works for
any space bound.
In general, the
space bound, I think,
grows to the square
of its original,
if you want to convert
non-deterministic
to deterministic.
This is useful for Rush Hour,
because to play a Rush Hour
game, in general, the number
of moves you might have to make
is exponential, so
it's not obviously
in NP, because NP
would have to have
a short polynomial-length
solution that you
can check in polynomial time.
But Rush Hour, you can
solve in polynomial space
if you're really lucky
because you say, well,
what move should I make?
Well, I'll guess one,
then I'll make that move.
Guess another move.
Make the move.
And just maintaining
the state of the board
only takes polynomial space.
So then if you solve
it, you're happy.
If there's no way to solve
it, you will return No.
I guess you have a timer.
After you've made
exponentially many moves,
if you still haven't solved
the puzzle, you can return No.
And in the lucky
world, that means
you will find a solution
if there is one.
Conveniently, lucky
algorithms can
be turned into
regular algorithms
when you're only worried
about space bounds.
And so that's how you prove
Rush Hour is in PSPACE.
So that's a good fact to know.
Cool.
All right.
There's one key thing
we haven't defined yet,
which is as hard as.
So let's get to that.
This is really the
heart of the class.
Let me go up there.
So this class is really
all about one notion,
and that notion is reductions.
So if I have two
problems A and B, then
there's this notion of
a reduction from A to B.
This will be an algorithm.
For us, almost all the time
it will be a polynomial time
algorithm, although you could
put in a different adjective
here than polynomial time.
Most of the time,
that is what we want.
And it's going to convert an
instance of the A problem--
so instance just means input--
and we'll convert it into an
instance of the B problem.
And it's going to do so in a
way such that the solution to A
equals the solution
to B. I mean,
the solution of
that instance of A
is the same as the solution
of the instance to B.
So this is-- think
decision problems.
The answer's either Yes or No.
So we want to convert A into
an equivalent instance of B,
equivalent meaning that
it has the same answer.
Why do we care?
Because let's suppose we
had an algorithm to solve B.
That would be this arrow.
So let's say if we
can solve B, then
we can solve A by this diagram.
Take an instance of A, convert
it into an equivalence of B,
solve B, and then that solution
is equal to the solution to A,
so we solved A.
This is as hard as.
So what we say is
B is as hard as A.
That's a definition
of this hardness.
In general, depending on
your definition of reduction,
you'll get a different
notion of as hard as,
but we will stick primarily
to polynomial time.
Reductions.
This is what you might
call a one call reduction.
This is kind of a technicality.
Also called a Karp
style reduction
because Karp gave a whole bunch
of them in the '70s, '80s.
So the idea is you only get to
call your solution to be once.
In general, you could imagine
an algorithm that calls
your solution to be many times.
That would also be a
notion of as hard as.
For the problems we'll look,
basically, these two notions
don't seem very
helpful, let's say.
So we'll stick to
one call reductions
because they seem
sufficient for everything
that we will cover
in this class.
Probably.
Maybe in some very
late lecture, we'll
talk about multi-call
reductions.
But they're not so prominent.
One call reductions are the
bread and butter of hardness.
So as you might imagine, this
is how you prove a problem hard.
Basically, all hardness
proofs in the known universe
are based on a reduction.
You start from a
problem which you
know is hard in whatever
class you care about,
and you reduce from that
problem, the known hard
problem, to your problem
that you're not sure about.
If you can do that,
then you prove
that your problem is as hard
as the original problem.
If you know that one is
hard, than this one is hard.
Don't get this backwards.
You will anyway, but try
not to get it backwards.
You're always reducing
from the known hard problem
to your problem.
OK.
So usually say, our proof is
based on a reduction from--
pick your favorite problem.
Never two.
Easy to get wrong, because
it's easy to make a sign error.
But that's life.
So good.
Anything else?
Now if you've taken
an algorithms class,
you've seen lots of reductions.
Reductions are a powerful
tool in algorithms too.
For example, some
lame examples like,
if you have an unweighted
shortest path problem,
you can reduce that to a
weighted shortest path problem.
How do you do that?
You set all the weights to 1.
Yay.
Why would you do that?
Well, never mind.
It kind of illustrates
what's going on here.
What we're showing is
that A is a special case
of B. Unweighted shortest
paths is a special case
of weighted shortest paths.
In some sense, all
reductions are that,
but they're usually
much less obvious
than unweighted shortest paths
to weighted shortest paths.
And the reason we
can say B is as hard
as A is because [? modular ?]
this conversion algorithm
A is a special case
of B. So of course,
if B has more cases than
A, or maybe the same,
but if it has at least as many
cases as A, then of course,
B is at at least
as hard to solve
as A in this formal sense.
OK.
Cool.
There are more
interesting examples
you've probably seen
in problem sets,
like if you want in
the arbitrage problem,
you want to find a path that
has the minimum product of all
the values, to convert
products into a min.
Some problem, you just take
logs of all the values.
So the reduction is compute
logs and all the weights.
So you've probably seen
lots of things like that.
Some are more
complicated than others.
What we're going to do in this
class is reduce instead of--
so for algorithms, you
want to reduce to something
you know how to solve.
We're going to
reduce from something
we know we can't solve
under certain assumptions.
So assuming P does not
equal NP, if A is NP-hard
and we reduce from A to B,
then we know the B is NP-hard.
That's a theorem.
So in this situation,
if we have a reduction,
let's say if A reduces to
B, I'll be explicit, and A--
better get this right.
It would be pretty
embarrassing if I got it wrong,
but I probably will get it wrong
at some point in this class.
Hopefully not today.
Then B is X-hard.
OK.
That's actually kind
of a trivial theorem
if you read all the definitions.
What did X-hard?
It meant as hard as
every problem in X.
And as hard as meant
there was a reduction.
So that means-- get this right--
there's reduction from every
problem in X to your problem.
So if A is NP-hard
there's a reduction
from every problem
to A, and we're
saying now what if there's
also a reduction from A to B,
well then, we can
just chain those
are two reductions together,
convert any problem in X to A,
then convert it to B. And so
we've shown every problem in X
can be reduced to B,
where B is X-hard.
This is an easy theorem.
The converse would be if B
can be solved in class X,
and X contains
polynomial time, then
you could can also solve A
in the same complexity class.
So for example,
if B is in PSPACE,
then we learn that
A is in PSPACE.
Something like that.
Cool.
Any questions at this point?
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You've talked
a lot about thi NP thing.
Why don't you ever talk about
non-deterministic exponential
orobelms or things like that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah, I didn't define
non-deterministic exponential
problems, but that's
a valid thing.
I think it's usually
written NEXP.
And I believe there
is a class of games
that naturally fits into NEXP.
Its mainly an issue of
which classes commonly arise
in problems that we care about.
This is a pretty rare
one, but I think there
might be one instance where--
we might touch on this.
Yeah, we definitely can.
It's the same open problem
where EXP equals NEXP.
I mean, it's another
open problem.
I shouldn't say it's the same.
I think you could solve
one without the other.
Again, everyone believes
you can't do it.
If you believe
you can't engineer
luckiness, then of course,
NEXP doesn't equal EXP.
But that would fit
right after EXP.
If you get NEXP, and
then you get EXPSPACE.
According to the things we've
written down and cared about,
that would be the
order of things.
Of course there are
classes in between these,
but these are the ones
that appear normally.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we know how to
use hardness assumptions,
for example, P not
equal to NP to say
whether there exists problems
that are not in P nor NP
complete?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's another
big open question.
Let's say P does not equal NP.
Are there problems here?
Which is to say strictly
in between being--
so they're still not in P
to the right of this line,
but they're also easier
than NP-complete problems.
There are a couple
problems that are famously
conjectured to live there, like
factoring integers and graph
isomorphism.
But I'm not aware of any
nice complexity class there.
You can, of course, say--
you can talk about
a class of problems
that are as hard as graph
isomorphism in a certain sense,
that if you believe--
if you have a graph isomorphism
Oracle, what can you do?
So there's a little bit of work
trying to chart that space,
but I'd say in general, it's
been not super successful.
Don't quote me on that, though.
I also don't know the
literature super well there.
So that's a big uncharted
territory, let's say.
Could be a big project.
Probably lots of
open problems there.
Other questions?
I think most people believe
there are things there.
One thing you could
prove is there's
a thing called exponential
time hypothesis, which
would say that [? sat ?] has
no sub-exponential algorithm.
Nothing to the
[? little o of ?] N.
If you believe that,
then it's known
there are some
things in between.
You can pick your
favorite function, like N
to Log [? Log ?] N. That's
bigger than polynomial,
but smaller than exponential.
And there are problems that are
in that class and not [? NP. ?]
So definitely with
ETH, you can do it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So regarding
that question,
I think it has been proven
that if P not equal NP, then
there is stuff in there.
PROFESSOR: Oh, there is.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or you can kind
of do a diagonalization.
PROFESSOR: Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the decision
problem for the factoring?
PROFESSOR: Decision
problem for factoring.
I think one version is
I give you a number,
and I give you a
bit position, and I
want to know whether there
is a factor that has a 0 or 1
in that position.
So if you can solve the
problem, then by repeated calls,
you could actually find
a factor that's not 1.
I don't know if there's a
better version than that.
You have to be careful, of
course, if you say, well,
is the number prime?
Then that's in polynomial time.
That was a big result
a bunch of years ago.
So, yeah.
Most of the time, it's easy
to go from your optimization
problem to a decision problem.
But factoring is one
where it's less clear.
More questions?
That was a lot in a
small amount of time.
But that's all you should
need from complexity theory.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: OK.
I guess I have a question
about the way you defined NP
with the [INAUDIBLE] algorithms?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
AUDIENCE: So the
definition that I've
seen before is in
terms of [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And there, it
specifically constrains
every branch in the computation
to run polynomial time,
whereas you can imagine a lucky
algorithm that avoids infinite
looping just because it's lucky.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
OK.
Yeah.
I was a little vague here.
For the definition of NP
, I said polynomial time
in the worst case.
Probably I need to say it's
polynomial time no matter
what branch you take.
Not sure it matters.
Because maybe if you
know your algorithm's
supposed to run in polynomial
time, you could have a timer,
and if it ever exceeds
that time, just return no.
So you might be able
to convert the weaker
notion of polynomial
time to the stronger one.
But it won't matter too much.
I mean, in all the
algorithms we'll think about,
every branch you could
possibly think of even,
the non-lucky ones,
are polynomial time.
So we will stick to that.
We won't spend much
time in general proving
that problems are
in NP or NPSPACE,
only to check that this
is the right class we're
supposed to be working in.
We'll spend most of our time
proving the hardness cases,
the lower bounds.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that if you
use different notions of a
reduction, different limit
space equally on
the competition,
you get different
measures of as hard as.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So as your
classes get bigger,
does it matter if you start
using more polynomial time
in your reduction?
Does it actually change?
PROFESSOR: I'm sure it matters.
But again, it's
beyond the classes
that are usually considered
from an algorithmic standpoint.
Bigger than these classes
don't seem to matter much.
And in these, maybe
once I've seen like,
a polynomial space reduction
to prove X-hardness,
so it's a slightly
weaker notion than if you
do a polynomial time
reduction, but if you
believe PSPACE does not equal
X, but still a separation.
So sometimes, things
like that happen.
I think the most common is
just switching to a space
measure over time measure.
I don't think it will matter
in anything we see here.
But it does arise
in the literature.
Definitely.
I think PSPACE or log space
are the two common ones.
And of course, when you're doing
P-completeness, it's another.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
setting it [INAUDIBLE],,
and I'm curious how
you could do that.
Because for any
instance of the problem,
you can't say that I've
used exponential time.
It could just be that there's
a bigger constant out front.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah, so you need to know
what the polynomial is
for it to have a timer.
That's a small catch.
Yeah.
I don't see an easy
way to avoid that.
Yeah.
There's some few subtle
constructive issues there.
If you don't know
what the bound is,
then things get more annoying.
None of those things
will happen in reality.
So remember, this not
a complexity class.
We're looking at
algorithms here.
This part is actually easy.
It's all about the reductions.
That's where the meat
of this class will be.
And for that, we need
to get NP-hardcore.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
PROFESSOR: I think all of
you soon will be NP-hardore,
and we'll be able to prove
really hard problems really
hard.
So in the spirit
of NP-hardcoreness,
we're going to take the classic
of hardcore video games, Super
Mario Brothers.
And our first proof will be
that Mario Brothers is NP-hard.
This got lots of
press, like here's
Kotaku saying, "Science
proves old video
games were super hard."
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
PROFESSOR: This is proving
the obvious, I guess.
But anyway.
So let me tell you a little
bit about how this proof goes,
and then we will see it.
All right.
So we need a problem
to reduce from.
The problem is 3SAT.
This is probably the most
common problem to reduce from.
We will spend a bunch
of lectures on it.
It won't be our very
next class, but we
will get to it pretty soon.
This is also known
as 3-Satisfiability.
If you're ever trying
to prove NP-hardness
and you don't know where to
start from, the answer is 3SAT.
Almost always, but not always.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Whatever.
So what's the problem?
You're given a 3CNF formula.
This means something
like x5, or I'll
be nice and write
English, or x3, or not x1.
And another thing like
that. x7, or not x2, or x5.
Whatever.
So some key words
you should know.
xI's.
Those are called variables.
xI or not xI.
Those are called literals.
You have two choices.
You could either have
a positive variable
or a negative variable.
Then you always have
three literals per clause.
These things are called--
each row of this thing that
I drew is called a clause.
The whole thing's
called a formula.
And the question is, can
you make this formula true?
So that's what you want to know.
Do there exist xI's such
that the formula is true?
That's the decision problem.
And it's NP-complete.
It is almost the first
problem proved NP-complete.
It's like the second
problem that's NP-complete.
The first one was without
this particular style.
It was just a bunch of
ands and or's and nots
in any combination.
But this is also hard,
and it's usually easier
to start from this situation.
So what we want to do
is reduce from 3SAT
to Super Mario Brothers.
OK.
So let's do it.
So I should mention our proof
holds Super Mario Brothers
1, Lost Levels, and 3.
Super Mario Brothers
2 is another world.
Also, Super Mario
Worlds, I think 1 and 2.
But most the pictures will be
Super Mario Brothers Original.
So what we're going to
do are build gadgets.
Gadgets are in this
case little pieces
of levels that we're
going to join together
to make the actual reduction.
So it's usually--
it's not typical
that you look at the instance of
A, and just think really hard,
and then just output an
instance of B from nowhere.
You just say, well, OK, instance
of A has lots of little pieces.
It's got variables,
and literals,
and clauses, and a formula.
I'm just going to take
each of those little pieces
and convert them into a
little piece in my output,
and then just string
them altogether
in a usually fairly obvious
way, though sometimes, there's
some subtleties there.
Almost all of our proofs
will follow this structure.
This is gadget
structure, and this is
the thing you're here to learn.
And it's super cool.
Because once you know
that you want to do 3SAT,
you're like, OK, I need
variables in closets.
So here's the variable.
Got Mario on the top.
Mario has to decide should
he go left or right?
I mean, you could
go back, but if you
want to go through
this gadget, you
can either fall
left or fall right.
And all of these heights
are so large that once you
make that decision, you can't
come back up because you
have a limited jump height.
OK.
Here's the clause gadget.
So the idea of variables
we're choosing,
do I set x5 to be true or false?
Let's say the left branch
corresponds to true,
the right branch
corresponds to false.
How that happens,
we'll see in a moment.
That's about how the
gadgets fit together.
Clause gadget has two parts.
On the one hand, you have
these three entry points
where your goal is to hit
koopas and bounce them around.
And then the other part is down
here, is a bunch of bricks.
And at the end of the level,
we're going to set it up
so Mario has to go
through this part.
And this will be
traversable if and only
if these bricks
have been broken.
So how would you do that?
This brick-- well, various
things are in the way here,
so what you need to do--
interesting.
But we're going to change
this gadget in a second.
I already see some
issues with it.
But this was our original.
Original proof
didn't get published,
and we ended up fixing it
before we submitted it.
So the idea is what we want
Mario to do is come down here,
hit the koopa, and then
knock the shell out here,
and it will bounce
and eventually break
all these bricks.
Right?
Well, no, that would be
Super Mario Brothers 3, where
turtles actually break bricks.
In Super Mario
Brothers 1, they don't.
So we will use a
different gadget
with fire bars and
question blocks
with invincibility
stars in them.
OK.
So same idea.
There are three
entrances down here.
If you hit any one of
them, then the star
will just float
around here forever.
We tested it.
It goes there for as long
as the level can last.
Then later, if you come
here, lots of testing
involved, of course.
Later if you come into here,
and you can get the star,
you have just enough time to
run through all these fire.
Bars if you don't, you will die.
OK?
So that's the clause gadget.
So if you visit in at least
one of these three places--
you can visit all
of them, it doesn't
help to have three stars
versus one in this case,
because they don't
stack or anything--
then and only then can you
go through the top part.
This is what we might call
a traversal, and this is--
you could call it setting
the gadget to True.
How does this all fit together?
This is sort of
the bigger issue.
So we're going to take
this three set instance.
It's got variables and clauses.
And let's ignore the
negations for now.
Am I going to ignore them?
No, I'm not going
to ignore them.
But on the one hand,
we have variables.
On the other hand,
we have clauses.
And we're going to
connect each variable
to the clause that contains it.
So this is an actual set
of four clauses here,
and you can trace them all.
So the claim is that
x in the positive form
appears in the first clause
and the second clause.
You can see there's an
x here and an x here.
It appears in the negative
one-- this is not x--
in clause three and four,
because here's not x and not x.
And so on.
So that's what all these
connections in the middle are.
In general, it's kind
of a bipartite graph.
You've got variables on
the one side, clauses
on the other side,
and we happened
to have coalesced
things in these groups.
What these edges are now
going to be converted into
are paths for Mario to follow.
So this is the variable gadget.
It's this thing.
We're just going to
plug that in here.
So the idea is you
enter from here,
and then you have two
ways that you can go,
either the true way
or the false way.
If you set the
variable to True, you
can then go and visit
the corresponding clauses
that contain it and
get one of the stars.
OK.
Now, for each
variable, you only get
to make one of
those choices then
you satisfy all the causes
that contain that literal.
And then when you're done, you
can walk to the next variable.
So there's actually two
entrances to the variable.
I guess that kind of matters.
What we want in the variable--
so you came from
the True setting,
or you came from
the False setting,
you don't want to be
able to run and jump over
to the other side
and the satisfy
the previous variable
both true and false.
You only get to make one choice.
Lots of things check here.
Then in the end, at the
very end after you've
set the last variable,
you have to traverse
all of these clauses
through the fire bars.
And that's going to be
possible if and only
if every one of the
causes has a star in it.
In other words, the variables
satisfy all the clauses.
In other words, the
formula is true,
because the clauses are
combined with an and.
OK?
That is in a nutshell the proof.
Once you've made
this construction
that the solution to 3SAT is
equal to the solution to Mario
in general, you want to
prove on the one hand
if the answer is yes
to 3SAT, if there's
a valid setting
for the variables,
then there is a solution
to this Mario instance.
You can actually
solve the level.
The decision question
here is, can I make it
to the end of the level?
There's a flag over there.
And conversely, if there is an
actual solution to this puzzle,
you want to show that
you can convert it
into a valid setting for 3SAT
that satisfies the formula.
You need to check both.
That gives you
the equality here.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Don't you need
this graph to be planar?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
This graph is not planar, and
so there are these crossings.
So there's one more gadget,
the crossover gadget.
And this is on the poster,
so if you were analyzing it.
There are many ways
to do crossover,
and this one is kind of
overkill unless I tell you
that Super Mario Brothers
has tons of hacks and cheats
that you can play,
and run through walls,
and crazy things.
But never mind that.
The idea here is
you are a big Mario.
At the beginning of a
level, there's a mushroom.
And you better not lose it.
Otherwise, you're in trouble.
So on the one hand, I can
go from left to right.
It's a directional crossover.
Or I can go from--
this is the bottom to the top.
But I can't go from
bottom to right.
I can't go from bottom to left.
All these sorts of things.
Why?
OK.
Let's do the
positive case first.
Say I'm from the bottom.
I fall here.
Can't go back.
I can jump.
If I'm big Mario, I can break
through a couple bricks,
and then I can escape.
OK?
But I could run under here.
For example, if you're good,
you can crouch slide, and then
jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
You get to here.
But you cannot get through this.
Or maybe I need to
add one more wiggle.
A little easier
to see over here.
Maybe I can get
here and move over.
But if you're in
this position, you
have no momentum you
can gain, and so you
can't crouch slide into there.
So if you're here coming from
the bottom, you can't get out.
Alternatively, if you
come from the left--
it's so tempting
to kill the goomba.
But instead of
killing him, you take
damage, become small
Mario, then you
can traverse through
here, because you
don't need to crouch slide.
You just jump.
And there's another mushroom
for you to restore big Mario
and restore the invariant.
And you better take it
because otherwise, you
can't get out through here.
So you're almost forced to go
left to right or bottom to top.
Now if you traverse
both of these gadgets
in both directions,
then all bets are off.
Then you can go from
anywhere to anywhere.
That's OK.
Because what we're
worried about in
this reduction is whether
you can reach certain things.
If you can reach something, I
don't care whether you reach it
now or later.
It's just you don't
want to be able to reach
unreachable things.
When you set the
variable to True,
I don't want to be able to
visit this false vertex ever.
And if you check
all the crossovers,
it's enough to build this kind
of thing, which either you
traverse left to right,
or bottom to top,
or you can reach both
the left and the bottom,
and then you can reach anything.
And you never have
to go right to left.
You never have to
go top to bottom.
Because we always know
the order in which
we're traversing
things and so on.
OK.
I think I've waved
my hands enough.
There are details to check,
but if you're interested,
you can wait 'til this part
of the class, where we'll
cover the Legend of Zelda,
Pokemon, Metroid, and I'm
missing one.
Donkey Kong Country.
Donkey Kong Country
is PSPACE-complete.
That's a hard proof.
No pun intended.
So that was Super
Mario Brothers.
Any more questions?
You asked the right one.
I would have gone
to it otherwise.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you
sure we'll never have
to go say, left to right twice?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's a good question.
In this gadget, we are not
able to go left to right twice,
but that's OK.
What's not really drawn
here but should be is
we're really taking an
Euler tour of this star,
so we're going to go
sort of on the left path.
There's actually two
paths down here maybe.
We're going to go
down here, then
we'll come back the other way.
Here, there are
actual crossovers.
When we come back, there are
different crossover gadgets.
Or you could say there's two
crossover gadgets for each
of these, one for going one
direction, one for coming back.
Yeah.
Four crossovers for
each intersection,
for both directions
and both guys.
AUDIENCE: I'm mostly
willing to believe you,
but I just have this nagging
doubt that you can't actually
arrange all these things
and make them fit together.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So there is a top level question
which is, in general, it's
the gadget assembly problem.
If I have all these gadgets, can
I actually put them together?
And it's important,
the output instance
should have polynomial size.
I probably should
mention that here.
It's important.
Of polynomials.
Oh, that's polynomial
time algorithm.
Good, good, good.
Yes.
So this is in parentheses.
Because it's a polynomial
time algorithm,
you will generate a
polynomial size output,
because our outputs have to
be represented explicitly
for reduction.
So the main issue
is, can you draw this
in a grid of polynomial size?
And the short answer
to your question
is, use standard graph
drawing algorithms.
If I give you a planar graph,
I can draw it with n vertices.
I can draw it in a grid
that order n by order n.
I forget what the best bound is.
Maybe 6n by 6n.
Doesn't matter here.
Now this graph is not planar.
But if you just add a vertex
for every intersection,
and there's at most n
squared intersections,
then I will have a planar graph.
Then I apply that algorithm.
It draws everything into a grid.
I explode that grid
by a factor of 100,
whatever the largest size of
this gadget is, plunk them in,
and then I route the tunnels.
So the only thing I
haven't really filled in
is how do you route the tunnels
to make them traversable?
Because if you go up,
you've got to have
enough stairs along the way.
But it's an exercise
for the reader.
There are definitely
details there.
And in some cases,
they are subtle.
I'll tell you the most
annoying issue that
can happen is a parity issue.
Sometimes, these gadgets--
I mean, you could make them
slightly wider or slightly
taller.
It doesn't matter.
Sometimes they have to
be even size or odd size.
And then things don't
always fit up well.
And that's a pain to do.
And I had a proof last
month, where I had,
I think, three separate
parity issues in a row.
I fixed one, and it's
like, yes, I got the proof.
And it was like, uh-oh,
there's another parity problem.
Then I fixed that one.
And then, uh-oh, there's
another parity problem.
And finally, the proof
is hopefully correct.
And we might go through
that as an example.
So there are
definitely issues that
can come up in gadget
assembly, but this one
I'm not worried
about, let's say.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Did the original
Super Mario Brothers
allow you to go left?
PROFESSOR: No.
In the original
Super Mario Brothers,
you cannot scroll
the screen left.
Mario can go left.
So this is all one screen.
You always have to generalize
something in your problem.
And if you say the size of
your screen, it's 320 by 240,
or whatever in the
original is constant,
then you can solve
Mario in polynomial time
by dynamic programming.
So that's not as interesting.
Mario 1.
Of course, any other
Mario, you can go left,
except sometimes it forgets
the status of your monsters.
Again, if you have that, you
can solve it in polynomial time
by dynamic programming.
So we're in the
sort of, we'll say,
as intended model, which is
you can have a big level.
4K is already happening.
Imagine the future, you
have a giant screen,
and you play a giant level.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: Other questions?
Now, one question is is Mario
Brothers an NP conjecture?
No, I think by now we
might have a proof that
is PSPACE complete.
But that's not published
yet, or even written yet.
So it's certainly not
guaranteed, but we think so.
OK.
Last proof is Rush Hour.
Before I get to Rush Hour,
I'm going to tell you
about another source problem.
So 3SAT is the most
common problem for--
you might call
them short puzzles.
Mario Brothers is
maybe a short puzzle.
If you have a time
limit in Mario Brothers,
then you're guaranteed
you're going to make at most,
let's say, n moves, and
then the game is over.
You either dire or you finish.
And 3-Satisfiability is a
good representation of that.
For longer games, another
model called constraint logic
or constraint graphs is useful.
So let me tell you this problem.
It's in some sense
simpler than 3SATs.
On a graph, you have red
edges and blue edges.
Notice the blue
edges are thicker.
That means they're twice
as heavy, so that you
think of this as your machine.
Now a state of the
machine is going
to be an orientation
of the graph.
So every edge is just
going to be oriented
one way or the other.
And the constraint--
in general, this
is called a constrained graph.
And the constraint
you have to satisfy
is that at every vertex, you
have at least two units of flow
pointed into the vertex.
So here there's actually three
units of flow pointed in.
There's the red single unit
and the blue double unit.
Blue's always 2,
red is always 1.
So if you get the Kindle
edition of this book,
don't read it on a
black and white display.
Or the PDF, whatever.
So what you're allowed
to do in this game,
the move you're allowed
to do, is reverse an edge.
As long as you always
satisfy this invariant
that at least two units
are in, then you're OK.
So I think here, we're going
to reverse this one first.
So now we have three
units of flow pointed in.
You have to check that the
other vertice's satisfied,
but this one's certainly OK.
Now because there
are two red units,
we can reverse the blue one.
And we cannot reverse
the red ones right now,
because that would leave only
one unit of flow inwards.
There's always two.
So in fact, this vertex that
I've drawn is in some sense
an AND gate.
We call it an AND
vertex, because it's not
a regular gate.
Over here, we're
going to think of--
it's a little bit asymmetric.
We're going to think of these
as the inputs to the gate,
and this as the
output of the gate.
And if the inputs are
pointing out, that's a false.
If they're pointing
in, that's a true.
And the output is reverse,
so if it's pointing in,
that's a false.
If it's pointing
out, it's a true.
So here's one
state false, false.
And so the AND of false
and false is false.
Here's another state where
both inputs are true,
and then the output can be true.
It doesn't have to be, though.
So in this example, let's
say we reverse this edge.
So now, we have false and true.
Still, we can't reverse this
because false and true is
false, and because
there would only
be one unit of incoming flow
before we can reverse this.
If I could reverse it back, I
could reverse the other one.
Only once I reverse
both of the inputs am
I allowed to reverse the output.
But I don't have.
I could just let it sit there.
It's not a gate in
the sense that it
doesn't compute the answer.
But what you know is that if
you have an output of true,
you know that the
inputs must be true.
So it's kind of an AND.
We call it a
constraint logic AND.
Now here, this I claim is an OR.
Now if you look at this in a
graph, it's totally symmetric.
It's just three blue edges.
But if you think of these
two as inputs and these two
as outputs, it's an OR.
And so what's the point?
Well, if I reverse any of the
edges, the incoming edges,
the input edges I
should say, then
I can reverse the bottom edge.
I don't have to.
And I could also do both true.
This could still
be true, and so on.
AUDIENCE: So if
it's symmetric, how
do you constrain some of
them to be inputs and others
to be outputs?
PROFESSOR: The inputs
and output distinction
is only in your head.
The way that I
used it is I said,
an input is true if
it's pointing in,
an output is true if
it's pointing out.
So that's asymmetric,
and it's just
a way of interpreting what's
happening in the graph.
the graph knows no difference.
This is useful, of course,
because your output
is the next vertex's
input probably
if you're building a
bunch of ANDS and ORs.
If you're building
a regular circuit.
So you want that definition
to be asymmetric.
It gets a little bit
confusing, and we
will spend a lot more
time on constraint logic.
This is more of a teaser.
But that's just in
the naming of things.
Naming of true and false.
OK.
So constraint logic, let's say,
what's the decision problem?
I give you such a graph.
Notice every vertex is either
an AND, two red and a blue,
or an OR, three blues.
And I want to know, can
I reverse that edge?
This is actually a crossover
gadget if you're curious.
In this world,
crossover gadgets,
you can just build
using ANDs and ORs.
There's no NOTs in this world.
NOTs don't even make
sense because you
can't force anything.
But it turns out this
problem is PSPACE complete.
So even harder than
3SAT, assuming NP
does not equal PSPACE.
And the cool thing is
once you have developed
all that infrastructure, if you
want to take a puzzle like Rush
Hour--
so these are cars.
Each car can slide in
the direction of the car,
no turns allowed, and your
goal is to get some car out,
or to move some car
at all, let's say,
I need to do two things.
I need to construct an AND
date and construct an OR gate,
and then I need to check
that they fit together.
So let me convince
you this is an AND
with this kind of orientation.
And yeah.
So this is going to
feel a little backwards.
Inward pointing means
that the block is out,
and outward pointing
means the block is in.
Ignore this picture
for the moment.
What happens here
is that if you want
to push C into this
gadget, imagine
the dark gray blocks are rigid.
They can't they can never move.
That's going to be true.
We'll see why in a moment.
So then it's just about
these inner guys moving.
If you want to
move C in one unit,
that will be possible if
and only if A moves out
and B moves out by one unit.
A moves out by one unit,
B moves out by one unit,
then this block can slide here,
this block can slide here.
This block can slide one,
this block can slide two,
and then C can move in one.
On the other hand, this
is an OR gate, OR vertex.
If A moves out one
or B moves out one,
then either E can move down,
or this guy can move down.
Once either of
those moves down, D
can move all the way to
the right or all the way
to the left, and then
C can move down one.
This is called a protected Or.
Small, subtle detail.
If A and B move out, then
everything can fall apart.
So basically, there's
a proof in this book
that says you don't need
to worry about that.
We can guarantee
that we'll never
have both A and B move out.
Only one of them will happen.
That's the protected part.
So that's basically the
proof of PSPACE-completeness
in two pictures.
This is the cool thing
about constraint logic
you don't need a crossover
gadget because those always
happen for free.
You just need to check that you
can fit the gadgets together.
And this is the intended
tiling to fit them together.
And you can check that as long
the box only move at most one
unit at any time, then
these gray regions are solid
all the way through.
I think I need to add
some more filler here.
And therefore, the gray
blocks can never move.
And so then, you can analyze
each gadget one at a time
and construct any constraint
logic graph in this way.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So for that
graph orientation problem,
I do not fully understand.
So you're given a graph--
PROFESSOR: You're given a
graph and an orientation,
and you want to know, can
I reverse this one edge?
So in this world,
it means you're
given an initial placement
of all the blocks,
and you know whether each thing
is in or out, because you know
whether the edge is
pointed to the left
or pointed to the right.
And you want to know, can
I move this one block?
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then for this graph,
you satisfied the property
that each vertex has at least
two units [? of input. ?]
PROFESSOR: Yes, the
input-oriented graph
should already
satisfy the invariant.
And then at every
move you do, you
have to also satisfy
the invariant.
AUDIENCE: Can you give a
small example of a graph which
satisfies that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: A small example.
Like this one?
This is not a single graph.
But if I connect this edge to
here, and this edge to here,
that will satisfy the property.
And it's one graph.
I don't have a small
example offhand
but I think you could make.
One
It's an interesting
question, what's
the smallest satisfied graph?
Probably 10 vertices or
something should suffice.
I should put it on
the problem set.
But later.
We'll talk about constraint
logic more later.
More questions?
So we did a lot.
We proved Mario is NP-complete.
I mean, some hand
waving involved.
We proved that Rush
Hour is PSPACE-complete
if you believe that constraint
logic PSPACE-complete.
In general, this whole
class is about reductions,
about taking a
known hard problem
and converting it
into your problem.
We will see a ton of them, and
each kind of type of problem
has a different flavor.
There's a whole range of
different 3SAT proofs.
This is not the
only form of 3SAT.
There are probably
a dozen of them .
But they all follow
the same pattern, which
is come up with a clause gadget,
come up with a variable gadget,
come up with ways to
connect them together.
And that's a very
useful way of thinking
about things for some problems.
And then for other problems,
you might use things
like constraint logic.
Constraint logic
is most relevant
when it's designed
around games and puzzles,
but it comes up in
other scenarios too.
I think in graph
labeling, there have
been proofs of
PSPACE-completeness
using constraint logic.
Next class, we'll
talk about a problem
called three partition, which
is really useful for problems
that involve numbers and adding
up numbers, where 3SAT isn't
really useful but three
partition turns out
to be the right thing.
So that will be next.
And that's all for today.